what's going on guys this is Rob and I
thought it'd be fun to do a daredevil
Easter eggs kind of thing and I've never
done this before
I've never actually done an Easter Egg
video and so I'm actually kind of
excited I'm kind of excited to see how
this will turn out but what I'm gonna do
here is I'm basically going to go over a
series of Easter eggs I found there may
be more that other people are aware of
but these are the ones that stood out
most to me so jumping into our list in
the number one spot is the incident
that's referred to in daredevil now we
know this incident is some kind of an
event that had taken place before
daredevil hit started and what we know
is that this is the result of Avengers
number one this is a result of the
battle in New York we know this because
there are several occasions when Ben
Urich the reporter is looking through
various things or we simply just get a
shot of him in his office and we see a
reference to the Battle of New York to
the event whereby loki had attempted to
invade the planet earth and take over
using the Chitauri anar me and so this
seems to be what it is are they're
referring to and this is really cool
because again it just takes some time to
remind us that daredevil is sharing a
universe with everything else while
daredevil is happening there's still a
litany of other things that are
happening Captain America is doing his
thing Tony Stark's doing his thing Thor
the Incredible Hulk and so on Black
Widow Hawkeye they were all out doing
their own thing while Daredevils taking
place and so it helps to keep things in
perspective the next Easter Egg on our
list is crusher creel the absorbing man
and this was actually really cool to me
though for those of you guys who don't
know crusher creel is a long-standing
character he actually appeared in
journey into mystery issue number 114
and he was created by Stan Lee and Jack
Kirby now crusher creel as the absorbing
man can basically couldn't I just turn
his body into a form of any material
that he can absorb any kind of steel
metal iron anything it really doesn't
matter what it is the result is that he
is virtually unstoppable if he absorbs
the right kind of material but the other
cool thing here is that in the daredevil
series we of course know that Jack
Murdock had gone on a fight crusher
creel and that was the fight that he
didn't throw which ultimately resulted
in his death but crusher creel also
appeared in agents of shield and we know
that he appeared as one of the people
who was assigned to track down and was
successfully able to do so then
capturing the obelisk which of course we
would know would later go on to discover
that it would house one of the Terrigen
crystals which is what turned Skye Argus
I guess allowed sky to develop her
inhuman powers but again much like our
Avengers Easter Egg this pretty much
reminds us that all this takes place in
a shared universe that all this stuff is
going on at the exact same time the next
Easter Egg we have here is Melvin Potter
Nunavut Potter was the guy who designed
the suit for daredevil he was actually a
guy that I daredevil had pursued after
learning that some kind of special
material was woven into the fabric of
kingpins outfits in order to keep him
safe from any kind of daggers or
presumably even bullets but a gladiator
I guess a Melvin Potter it first
appeared in daredevil issue number 100
I'm sorry issue number 18 and he was
created by Stan Lee and John Romita
senior in addition to this he would
actually undertake the mantle of
gladiator and effectively become a
criminal for hire but what would
ultimately happen is that he would
initially begin to confront daredevil
but then would actually turncoat and
become an ally of daredevil for quite
some time
the next person or I guess honest eat
next Easter egg which I don't really
think it's more of an easter egg as
opposed to a direct reference but this
is the character of rosario Dawson of
Clare temple and rosario Dawson is
literally a night nurse now the night
nurse was a four-issue limited series
that ran between 1972 and 1973 and this
basically told us how it was at various
superheroes were being patched up at
night whenever it was they went into
battle and so for those of you guys who
were always wondering where does Captain
America go whenever he gets injured
where is it that daredevil goes where is
it that a lot of these superheroes these
ground-level superheroes go whenever
they can't whenever they get hurt and
they can't go to a traditional Hospital
this is it they go to characters like
Claire temple who again are night nurses
that patch these superheroes up so the
next easter egg and this was actually a
pretty big one and one that I was a
little disappointed with this has been
uric now Ben Urich is a significantly a
wildly important character in the realm
of Marvel Comics I really can't state
how important he is he is a character
that appeared in daredevil issue number
153 this was his introduction to Marvel
Comics now much like we saw in the TV
show
I guess Ben Urich first real assignment
was an expose I guess on the kingpin
proper which basically exposed the
kingpin that's what made people aware of
the fact that the kingpin was a criminal
but more so than this Ben Urich actually
went on to do the same thing with Green
Goblin with Norman Osborn and he was
also a
sad Sally Floyd one of the reporters for
civil wars part of the Civil War
frontline series that gave us the
perspective of civil war from a
journalist standpoint now we saw of
course during civil war that I've been
Urich was confronted by Green Goblin
which was a return to the kind of expose
aids and the things like that that Ben
Urich had done on the Green Goblin but
the fact remains that Ben Urich would
have been a great character that Marvel
could have used to effectively segue
spider-man into the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but because of the fact that
Ben Urich has died in the daredevil
series we won't really see this
opportunity if so again it's a little
bit of a disappointment here the next
Easter Egg is the character of Elektra
and the reason why I say Elektra is an
Easter Egg here is because we get this
extremely small tiny little reference
and not a lot of people knew and we
found that foggy Nelson had reference to
Matt Murdock about a Greek girl they
knew in college and what it wasn't it
ever happened to her now Elektra was
Greek she was born on a Greek island but
more so than that she had been trained
she had operated with the hand she had
also become an assassin of the kingpin
and one of the foremost villains and
enemies of daredevil ultimately to find
herself killed by bullseye during Frank
Miller's run of daredevil but this was a
really really great reference here
because a lecture would be a fantastic
character to bring into the Netflix TV
series especially if they intend on
keeping the series dark with that being
said I hope you guys enjoyed this Easter
Egg video if you guys found any other
Easter eggs let me know post down in the
description or down on the comment
section let me know where you found
theirs I'd love to see what else you
guys spotted for the things that I
didn't see without being said I will
catch you guys whatever please be sure
to follow me on Twitter there you can
keep up with all the updates from comics
explained and talk to me directly
[Music]